the rise of the machines as automation
spreads through the American economy
experts say it's impacts will be uneven
in the world that we are creating very
quickly we're going to see more and more
things that look like science fiction
and fewer and fewer things that look
like jobs how does society companies and
employees adapt to this acceleration of
technology in both governments across
the world need a narrative that helps
people to feel that they do belong that
they are being heard that's one way that
they can start to rebuild trust hi
welcome to another cold fusion video the
Industrial Revolution has brought about
a change of seismic proportions no time
in human history has seen such an
acceleration of the economy and people's
standards of living while it created
many jobs it also displaced some today
another revolution is taking place this
time in software and hardware
however this revolution is different
compared to anything that has come
before technology is catching up to the
workforce faster and more widespread
than ever before where I live a lot of
supermarket checkout staff have already
been replaced and in the United States
truck drivers seem to be next even
radiologists accountants and lawyers are
being threatened by AI that can better
perform aspects of their jobs basically
with newer AI technologies like deep
learning as said by Google co-founder
Sergey Brin there is currently no clear
limit to what can be automated so the
question is if millions of people start
to lose their jobs through automation
and AI what impact will this have on the
modern economy and society it may not be
a guaranteed result but the risks make
it worth thinking about one of the most
general solutions to this problem is a
universal basic income or ubi so what is
ubi and what are the arguments around it
and what will the future of work look
like
you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
Universal basic income is an idea that
dates back centuries sixteenth century
philosophers wrote about a utopia where
each citizen is relieved of the burden
of worry over ensuring their essential
needs some of the earliest pilot tests
were conducted in the United States
during the 1960s and 70s Milton Friedman
the famous Nobel prize-winning economist
is known for his ideas on free market
economics and he was one of the main
supporters of a so-called negative
income tax but in recent times ubi has
been gathering momentum as technology
began to replace people from their jobs
the idea of guaranteeing every person
with a minimum living wage income is
becoming popular and regain a 2020
presidential candidate is even basing
most of his campaign around the idea of
ubi the idea is simple give every
citizen a monthly payout to cover their
basic living needs in the modern world
with the implementation and the question
of why we need ubi as you'll see is more
complex remember going to Blockbuster
there are a few staff there and many
other people behind the scenes
delivering the videos to the store and
so on or thanks to human ingenuity we
can now stream movies and TVs online in
the comfort of our own homes one could
argue that the Internet and Netflix
killed the video store clerk the same
has largely happened to supermart
checkout workers they've been replaced
by self-serve machines
researchers estimate between 20 and 30
percent of all jobs will be lost by
automation by 2030
here's a breakdown of those jobs that
will be lost by this time
so right now repetitive low-skilled work
is most at-risk of automation skilled
jobs may be at risk to a recent study
put lawyers and AI against each other
their task was to review non-disclosure
agreements it took the lawyers an
average of 92 minutes to complete the
task and they achieved 85% accuracy the
AI well it just took 26 seconds and it
achieved 94% accuracy Babylon is a
company he claims that their AI can pass
a medical exam with a higher average
grade than a human they've been
providing health care services to Rwanda
since 2016 a study found that hedge
funds using AI made a return of about
eight percent this is significantly
better than the ones that are managed by
humans which made a return of about two
percent in the same time frame in
military use an AI developed at the
University of Cincinnati was able to
defeat an experienced Air Force colonel
every time in a simulated air battle
another AI has also been developed which
can in some instances outperform
radiologists when determining diseases
based off x-rays it can detect shades
that the human eye can't sure we're
still going to need lawyers and doctors
in the future there are some key things
such as complex decision-making and
empathy that may never be automated away
and also just because an AI performs
well in test settings doesn't mean it's
ready for the market just yet but the
point remains if technology keeps
advancing we may need less humans to do
the same amount of work and it's not
just AI that we should be concerned
about
over the last few decades the top
percentiles of many countries have
gotten wealthier while the rest of the
population stagnate wealth inequality in
America is especially skewed with the
top one percent of American households
owning 40% of the country's wealth for
those curious as to why wealth
inequality is happening in the first
place it's largely because of central
bank monetary policy if you've watched
some of my older financial videos this
should be of no surprise but now I'm not
just saying it the Dutch central bank
recently came out with a study of over
the past hundred years including the 12
most advanced economies and they've come
to the same conclusion loose central
bank policy causes wealth inequality so
what does this wealth inequality mean
for a future where low-skilled labor is
being replaced by high-tech machines
well if things stay as they are it would
be logical to assume that the wealth gap
will keep increasing and perhaps even at
a greater pace than before right now the
problem has gotten so bad that in the
United States a new term has been
created the working poor the working
poor are people who earn below the
poverty line
despite actively working factors such as
low wages due to a lack of education
contribute to this pitfall a person can
be stuck in a feedback loop with little
prospect of escaping perhaps they can't
afford to go back to school
because they need to work to survive or
the lack of finances keeps them from
securing a better paid job approximately
11% of US families are classed as
working poor now ask yourself what
happens to these people when the basic
entry-level jobs become obsolete in the
face of technology
today the quantity of jobs lost and the
time frame in which jobs could be lost
is far greater and shorter than ever
before we're essentially raising the bar
of what is considered an entry-level
unskilled job by making technology which
is capable of that task we're pitting
humans against machines and there seems
to be a clear favorite humans can only
work about eight hours a day they need
lunch breaks and time off an algorithm
or a robot can work basically 24/7
it doesn't need any of that other stuff
if you're a CEO and just thinking about
profits it's not a hard decision to make
and this is where some people argue that
the money for ubi should come from
sometimes it's referred to as a robot
tax basically the money save should go
into other areas to help support society
Bill Gates argues that a robot tax would
be logical to insure a company is paying
its fair share companies with lower
automation wouldn't be taxed that much
but a company that heavily uses
automation would be taxed a bit higher
it's unlikely to stifle the progression
of automation simply the robot tax is a
proposed method of ensuring that the
increased productivity of automation is
captured by society and not just a
singular company so as said this money
could go towards the ubi system though
all of this is just a very rough idea of
ubi but there's one man that's taking a
very detailed look at the issue if you
accept that were the greatest economic
transformation we've already gotten rid
of five million manufacturing jobs four
million due to automation and 30 percent
of malls and stores are closing and
being a retail clerks the number one job
in the economy how do you solve that
problem 2020 American presidential
candidate Andrew yang is perhaps one of
the only politicians in the world
thinking seriously about this problem in
fact as mentioned he's based most of his
campaign around the issue yen proposes
$1,000 per month for a starting amount
for ubi
let's use it as an example people both
rich and poor would be entitled to
receive this payment you can opt out if
you feel that you don't need it with
this thousand dollars basically every
single person can be insured a minimum
standard so why is this better than the
current welfare solution well there's
people on both sides of the argument
firstly let's look at someone living on
welfare if that person was paid $1,000
per month by the state for being
unemployed it may incentivize them to
not seek employment as their welfare
payment would decrease or be taken away
completely once they've started earning
money from the job say they found a job
paying $2,000 a month depending on the
program and the country they may lose
their $1,000 welfare payment entirely
and hence might only be $1,000 better
off than they were on welfare now let's
suppose that this same person was
receiving $1,000 under EBI well if they
accepted that $2,000 job this person
would now be exactly $2,000 better off
than when they were unemployed and on
welfare of course there are different
and more complex examples of welfare
systems that attempt to curb this
disincentive but overall this is one
argument for ubi
it may help incentivize the lowest
income groups to work improving their
situation and the economy as a whole
however the argument then follows that
people who are inherently lazy and
unmotivated to work will be given an
excuse to keep being the way that they
are but it can also be said that this is
negligible compared to the increase in
productivity that we'll have from
automation and AI but then again it's in
people's human nature to not just
survive but live comfortably maybe a
better education for their kids a bigger
car or a bigger house there are more
motivations to work than simply covering
the necessities and this is what ubi
aims to address people might also
decrease their time at work in order to
spend more time doing what they love and
less of what they have to do but in the
face of increasing automation and AI
this may not be their choice and we'll
get to that in a bit so where is all of
this money magically going to come from
well as mentioned before that's where
taxes and companies join the
conversation with increases in overall
productivity and lower cost due to
automation companies may be more
profitable and hence pay more taxes
taking a look at the current welfare
system and Rianne believes that the
economics of EB I can work
according to yang the u.s. currently
spends 1.5 trillion dollars on various
welfare programs a national 1.8 trillion
would have to be necessary to introduce
his EBI speaking on various podcasts
including Joe Rogan's and Sam Harris's
young outlines that the size of the US
economy is approximately 20 trillion
with about 4 billion of that being the
federal budget
he claims according to several studies
giving the average American an
additional $1,000 per month would result
in 40 billion dollars in new tax due to
increased spending this is because the
money in the hands of the average
American would flow right back into the
economy as they would spend it on food
car repairs childcare and so on yang
cites studies which projects 2 million
new jobs and an 8 to 10 percent growth
in the economy do Tevi spending a
further 100 to 200 billion dollars will
be saved on incarceration and emergency
services as crime would be expected to
marginally decrease this is all educated
speculation on Yang's part but it's
still very interesting to think about
in total yang claims that about a
trillion of the 1.8 trillion required
can be claimed back by various net
positives there ubi creates the economy
the remaining eight hundred billion yang
attributes to tax and companies that are
profiting from the automation of jobs
much like the robot tax he argues that
much of the world already has something
called a value-added tax and if the
united states introduced this that even
at half the rent europe has it would be
able to claim that last 800 billion he
also goes on to say that alaska has
effectively had a type of ubi for
decades residents received $2,000 per
year from the state funded taxes from
oil companies essentially ubi is meant
to make sure everyone gets a slice of
the pie and not just the big oil or tech
companies as yang puts it technology is
the oil of the 21st century we do start
need to be thinking about this fast for
the sake of 3.5 million truck drivers in
the United States with the rise of
driverless cars companies are beginning
to realize the potential of driverless
trucks for the people affected it's not
a matter of if but when
[Music]
during the history of humanity from time
to time we experienced these massive
shifts
however they have happened over decades
or longer allowing people to get
retrained into new jobs to be created
from this technology the current changes
though are much faster and aside from
finding new jobs for masses of people
its said that historically
government-funded retraining programs of
displaced workers have had success rates
from 0% to 15% so not only do we need to
create jobs as quickly as the technology
is displacing it we would have to find a
way to become amazing at retraining and
that's not been the case historically
while jobs may be created from all this
disruption the question is how many jobs
and will these jobs be accessible to
unskilled workers who were displaced or
will be as newly created jobs require
skilled workers such as programmers and
data analysts early results from a
recent pilot program in Finland found
that ubi didn't help in getting people
who were unemployed into jobs but it did
make them happier and less stressed
about 50% of participants reported being
healthier and having a better overall
well-being while the rest remained the
same Y Combinator the startup
accelerator which funded air B&B will be
launching a ubi study in the United
States in 2019 after three years of
regulatory obstacles other experiments
are ongoing or a set to kick off soon in
Germany the Netherlands Italy and Uganda
many other governments are seemingly
interested in exploring the idea but we
may not know the success or failure of
ubi for a few more years after more
research is conducted on the backs of
these trial programs despite trials of
EBI being conducted as early as the
1960s there's still a lot we don't know
when it comes to the practical
implementations of the idea
one of the main arguments against TBI is
that it would subsidize people to be
lazy giving them an excuse not to work
this may be true to some extent former
vice journalist Tim Poole argues that
ubi will simply allow people to do
nothing while at the same time demanding
higher wages from jobs hence increasing
the cost of goods and services
Tim however does agree that in the face
of increasing automation something like
this would be necessary probably one of
the least discussed but potentially
devastating consequences of ubi is that
some economists think that such a
measure could collapse the entire global
economy so if you understand and can
recognize the data and math behind these
indicators then you don't have to so
much guess what's gonna happen you could
follow the data and this way you could
try to be on the right side of the trade
I believe that bond market will
absolutely implode in the near future
but you have them say that dynamic
behind that to prepare for the bond
market food from bond prices to implode
meaning crash and yield to skyrocket
you're gonna need the money multiplier
on m2 to skyrocket Lac that happened
you're gonna need things like modern
monetary theory universal basic income
your new you need to go around and
circumnavigate the banking system and
send cash directly to people that's all
coming in the wake of the next recession
it's just not gonna happen now as they
state the measure such as EBI could
cause the United States bond market to
crash a bond market crash is much worse
than a stock market crash or a recession
because this indicates a lack of
confidence in the fundamental fiat
currency or the government controlling
their currency and when that happens is
very hard to recover from and since the
US dollar is the world's global reserve
currency this could have a follow-on
effect much worse than the 2008
financial crisis but if I'm being honest
nobody really knows if this will happen
and no one really knows for a hundred
percent what
in terms of the economic consequences
another argument is that inflation will
be caused by the people demanding higher
pay and businesses hiking up the prices
as more people have money to spend
however a free-market would mean that
business competition would make sure
that the prices are as low as possible
and while prices may increase due to
wage increases it may be negligible
compared to the overall benefit of the
economy
Jordan Peterson clinical psychologist
and now famed internet personality also
argues against TBI but does agree that
is trying to address a problem we will
have in the future in a world and an
economy where robots outperform humans
however Peterson argues that money alone
wouldn't be enough to make people live a
happy life he notes that people need a
differentiated and delineated purpose
and simply giving people money without
that purpose is a wrong solution and
this may be the biggest issue that ubi
cannot solve
so in conclusion and to be clear when
free market innovation goes so far then
nobody has new work we have to start
thinking about things a little
differently it may be essential to curb
civil unrest and poverty if companies
begin to use robots as labour wealth
inequality may widen as the poor and
unskilled will no longer be able to find
work while still needing food and the
necessities that those companies produce
without some kind of tax or wealth
distribution system it might just be
that the owners of these companies may
be the only ones who reap the rewards
the main idea of uPA is ensuring that
people don't get left behind the market
is still free it's just an idea and a
solution to the process that we're in
when we start to approach peak
capitalism it will be a time we were so
efficient at creating goods and services
that we just no longer need large
portions of people for these jobs under
ubi people will have more free time to
enjoy activities such as spending time
with family and friends but human nature
has an inherent desire to be productive
and to contribute something meaningful
to the world sure a lot of people do
complain about their work
and they dream of winning the lottery
and never having to work again perhaps
these people may be happy for the first
few months of not working but a few
years down the road they may get the
feeling of a life without purpose when
it comes to ubi
people often flippantly say well now
everyone is free to pursue their own
passion but they forget the empathetic
angle everyone isn't them there are also
a lot of people in this world without
passions or hobbies it can be said that
curiosity is the start of passion follow
the trail of what you're curious about
and then develop that into a passion
others still might even find that hard
to do so what happens to them if
technology does replace their jobs and
they're unable to retrain then what
meaning will they find in life that's
personal to them and only they can solve
that problem so automation is on the way
advances in technology are too great to
ignore the people at the bottom of the
workforce are going to start being
replaced ubi may be able to solve the
issue of how everyone will be able to
feed themselves in this future but what
about that more burning question of
purpose now that might be harder to
solve so that wraps up our look at
universal basic income I think this
video is pretty important for people to
fully understand what's going on in our
world today if you did enjoy it it would
mean a lot if you could share it so more
people can learn if you want to see more
videos like this or anything in the
range of business science technology and
history I cover a range of topics on
this channel and there's some really
good stuff coming up so feel free to
subscribe there's also a new podcast
version of these videos coming up and
I'll leave a link for that below anyway
this has been - gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll see you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion if you thinking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]